so guys I wasn't originally going to do
this trailer review because I saw the
teaser and it's literally like 30
seconds of cool shots you know that's
really all it is I said to myself on
Twitter even I wrote if I did a review
for this movie I basically be like oh
look there's Mark Wahlberg oh look
there's a blonde Michael Bay chick oh
wow Dinobots that's really all this
trailer has to offer but what I can't
talk about is the fact that my most
anticipated movies of 2014 video I said
this movie was not one I was really
looking forward to seeing I am curious
about this movie though and I will of
course definitely be seeing it what I'm
not really that excited for is the fact
that it exists and it's another one
happening again and it's the same
director and they're taking it in a new
way but it's really not going to be
different because it's Michael Bay and
it's just really gonna more likely be
the same stuff over again except Shia
LaBeouf won't be screaming Bob a dumbass
the whole time
and you know what that's a plus the one
thing I'm most curious about is Mark
Wahlberg and what he's gonna bring to
this movie is he gonna bring something
to this movie that's better than the
previous three is he gonna bring that
actual leading man character credibility
that this movie needs or is he really
just going to be another body that can
run away from explosions and CGI robots
cuz to be honest some of the CGI in this
trailer didn't really impress me that
much and I'm assuming that it's not
entirely finished yet and yes you are
watching really quick cut images of
things but I looked at it online and I
freeze-frame through some of it and it
just looks like it needs some work still
I think I love Mark Wahlberg I think is
a very good actor I'm excited to see him
in this movie I am excited to see some
Dinobots because I grew up watching
beast wars in the 90s yes I did and I
loved that show I used to watch it every
day before school I still watch it from
time to time on Netflix so it's kind of
cool to see that Michael Bay decided to
put some Dinobots in this movie however
I just don't know if this movie is
necessary I would love to go out of that
movie and be like wow that is the best
Transformers movie that Michael Bay is
made I would love to see it be good I
hope it is good I'm just not really that
pumped for it yet and a trailer like
this doesn't really do that much for me
I'm still waiting for that full trailer
to see that typical Michael Bay humor is
in there or not hey it's got the girl
from The Last Airbender
so that's something
mm guys I already did my review for
Captain America the Winter Soldier that
is currently on my channel if you want
to watch that and I got one more trailer
review coming for you today and that is
going to be for the amazing spider-man 2
trailer look forward to that as always
guys if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes